une perte des prestations sociales c'est
le sort réservé aux familles des
professionnels de santé britanniques
ayant perdu la vie dans la lutte contre
le coc vide 19
le procédé est simple si une famille
accepte l'indemnisation du gouvernement
elle perdra automatiquement ses
prestations sociales
une mesure qualifiée de nouvelle gifle
au visage par le service national de
santé qui se sent trahi par les
autorités les familles qui acceptent la
somme de 60 mille livres soit un peu
plus de 65000 euros risquent de perdre
leurs droits à certains versements tels
que le crédit universel et les
allocations de logement ou de retraite
l'opposition dénonce une profonde
injustice le gouvernement ait eu raison
de dire que nous devons honorer ceux qui
ont fait le sacrifice ultime
il est donc choquant que les familles
soient obligés de choisir entre l'accès
à la sécurité sociale à laquelle elles
ont droit où l'indemnisation doit elles
ont besoin
de son côté le gouvernement défend un
principe de calcul équitable selon les
autorités britanniques seuls ceux qui ne
peuvent pas satisfaire leurs besoins
fondamentaux doit pouvoir toucher une
indemnisation
mais pour certains cette approche on
encourage pas les professionnels de
santé à risquer leur vie pour en sauver
d'autres
[Musique]
c'est très regrettable
cela a pris beaucoup de temps aux
organes représentatifs de tous les
professionnels de santé de négocier ceci
avec le gouvernement et puis le découvre
que cela sera finalement une sorte de
capitale cela constitue un pas en
arrière
cela ne doit être qu'une prestation et
il faut se souvenir que ces gens meurent
en première ligne pour sauver des vies
bien souvent en travaillant dans des
situations les protections individuelles
sont insuffisantes
il se met vraiment et franchement en
première ligne en danger et leurs
proches ne doivent pas être sanctionnées
sous prétexte d'avoir reçu cette somme
de 60 mille livres
la semaine dernière le gouvernement
britannique avait annoncé la refonte du
système de santé avec la mise en place
d'un nouvel organisme chargé de protéger
les britanniques 2
menaces extérieures contre la santé du
pays un projet vivement critiquée par le
parti travailliste qui déplore que cette
annonce intervienne en pleine pandémie